やっと撮影環境が整ってきたぞを持ちマーケ
ブーツ
数え社長ですたじゃあミューズ別府は東京新聞やっと撮影場所っぽくなってきました机
があれば他の撮影ができると思ってくれたらこういう感じで東京でも撮影していければ
いいなと思っていますそれで今日はちょっとしばらく東京に行ってやりたいこと
たくさんですけどもう色々と静岡に置いてきちゃって東京に縛らケルンでちょっとやる
こともないのでと悪者を3ヶ日ていきたいとおもいます
皆さん amazon で介護
のはしますでしょうかインターネットでぶつけるとなる上にダレットをよく使う人だっ
たら多分アマゾンでよく買い物すると思うんですけどもみなさんねユーチューバーと
いう生き物はアマゾンでどんなものを早くご存知でしょ
もうあ謎日々ユーザー家には常にあ謎の箱山積みになっていて演算を基本的な
amazon のダンボールでめちゃくちゃになってべ外に出ない引きこもりいい
にいるネットずっと触ってこれだけの要素があるともう基本的に赤さんですけどタイム
のしなきゃって言って今回はちょっと今日は落ち着いだと思うにしますはちょっと
のんびり軽い気持ちで見てください葉挿してボイラーのアマゾンの砲撃は果たして
どんなものを買っているのかという事を皆さん知は見せていこうと思います結構よって
変なの考えたら嫌だな
はいというわけでこんなある法名だあ隠せばいいのかだいたいをさせるつくでしょ
チェックした商品の関連商品は全部いう行カードでございますはいとけどちょっと僕の
今までやってきた2問履歴購入劇を見ていきましょう
俺も気になってきたので何か色々とかかってないよね2012年とか萌えなけれど
2012年あり勝ってたか調べてみよう
懐かしいなかったんだこれぐらい昔なんですけど
カラーバターっていう髪の毛を色をつけるやつを動かし買っています
これが2012年の年末か年末に買ってる
スラックラインとかなんかこういう日もう貼って遊ぶスポーツがあるんですけどの頃に
マック2010年にバックぶっぷ
ウエアを冠っていますんだと2012年はんな買ってない
んじゃねーよなもんですなまた2013年の何買ったんだろう
2013年1月には桜入れないやっぱちょっとゆちゅばっぽいですねここらへんから
2013にがちょっと youtube っぽい
レンズにかけるカバーとか一生フィルムと思っています山グルブーツっていうちょっと
ミリタリー系のブーツを買ったりした例目時の2チーロ+
通電したかったんですよねほぼのぬいぐるみリュック白タイプを買ってます画像があり
ませんね者らも吸収したければのぬいぐるみを買っています
何を考えていたんでしょうかアーバンタッチレンズキャップまあそうだ懐かしいなぁ
ここら辺なんかノコギリヤシとかあるヘアトニックとか
なんだなんかこのなんか人生だこの先俺ハゲーのかなと思った時期がありましてハゲる
の嫌だなと思って中ハ
えないようなものをここなんで買ってましたん
懐かしいな1回も使わなかったら一眼レフのケース付三脚&るグリップこうやって持っ
てカメラをとるやつですね
スンギえ俺やる気満々山マップ用のマイクロソフトエクセルとか powerpoint
を使おうと思ってここで待ってもそれを変えましためっちゃレンズキャップカーじゃん
で買いすぎでしょ俺もなんか怒ってるの
よくなくしたんだと思いますアイス d カードと向かってますね三脚
は数十2013年はなんか
行かれてたのかな2014年秋がおります紹介する2014年でございます
まあここは何だろうなゲーム実況したイチモツになったんだと思いますコンデンサー
マイクとか風のボーナスポップスクリーンと感なくウェブカメラとかゲームパッドあ
名がゴキブリも買ってますがその頃がちょっと孤独きれいに対する君なんかすぐコーチ
が湧いてたみたいですね
2年前か
pos とったなぁ俺もまだ見てたりブーツ2校がでがあります5レイヤーが着ぐるみ
6点セット照明を買いましたねあまた3期かかっているブーツ芸母が売ってるブース道
の akb を映像編が当たったないと覚えないと
何かっていうおもしろアイマスクもうあ懐かしい何かあっ僕が多分ね2年前ちょうどね
さんのサルエルパンツのブーム
が僕の中できてですごいされるかと開幕いましたんだまだをしている二点ちょっと魅力
を感じる時期がありますコカコーラゼロ1.5 l 発泡んはっ本
100本 a を何してんのこれあっ発送蛇行 love した時だ
ナッツを出そう発送ぞ
コーナー黒ああ望んで注文しました
若かったあの頃は分かって馬鹿丸出しだっています日本客とメントス12個入りでここ
らへんも完全にイカれてるなぁ野々村 t シャツ耳をすませばバージョン黒アクア
フォールを買ったしマネキン迎えましたねここでバットカード女子校生髪の匂いエビを
買いまくった後にあの今も使っているこたつに年間も使ってんだねよくハンマーで叩い
ても割れないこたつもやがて2周年でこ
がいます2階窓れステッカー食べに貼ってると海に行っている家もつになれる壁紙なっ
く book pro をここら辺で買っちゃったのかな
旗レンズキャップ買ってるじゃん鼻水が出てくる濃度ディスペンサー白雪姫バックルっ
として1ダメージですっここから俺はダメになりましたここら辺で多分で容量の限界を
感じたんでポータブルハードディスクを買って百味ビーンズユニバーサル自分で
ikea
ここらへんからですが外に年前から北は雪をにドハマリしちゃってここから多分のいう
行が多くなると思います
じゃカメラんでもって ene
だミリタリージャケットにハマった時期もありました国家がいいよ1070源氏垣外
それ系の何かモノを買ったじゃないですね
ひたすら遊戯王カードで試算されるヴェルディ方さ言葉の習得が母国習得で第二言語
習得
やっぱモデルガード2年前から使ってるんだね洗濯のりアスナの3部受かってる
文章読本調節真髄ツーリストリビングをアマゾンで買ったんん
ここでまた降りたり物がぴったり物解析でしょう服買いに行くの面倒くさかったんで
全部 amazon で買ってますと安いやつちっぱちゃってそのツリーを丸ごと変え
ましたやっぱ基本いう業だが爆竹立っている遊戯王カードしか勝手になっているところ
がありました次
2015年度が終わりますここは単焦点レンズを買ってテンションが上がっておりまし
た
ゲームレコーダー飼い始めた
見せかけて切っていうか遊戯王が振れよだそうだ何かでプレオ壊れてて1回な10ピン
というかやり取りをしたんですよね鼻毛カッターを買ってますね
鼻毛がは気になってたんですよねスーパーボウル300個セットかでなぜか人をダメに
するソファをもう1回勝ってる青梨のポストプレー賞とか見え買ってるんでここで服の
白が気になってた場合ローン神戸買いましたね
もう1年前から米ビルドしてたんだねなんやかんやベイブレードも長い期間やってます
がよく家に人が来るになって監視カメラを買って使わなかったんですけどいたずら
グッズの巨大分を買っていますでここで多分アイロンするときに
代が必要だと9 a が必要だともダイロン台を買いました気づくのが遅かったね
すごいでバスドラを買ってますね
ユギオカードが立派過ぎハマっているのが内の
1持っているベイマックスの姉組を買いましたか議員さんの t シャツを買ってます
水が行くセルを
オーダーを買ってやっぱ基本エラーも言い家で構成されてるな
なんでこれホットカーってるー
そうでホッと壁と重ねまくってたは弾かれるでこう悪球だよあってピザ6を買って
何かちょっとゆちゅばっぽいですね it 2016年で今年です
今年はもうなんて何やってたこれをよく覚えてるんだよ
人が住まず野菜嫌い t シャツ
なんで来なかったんだと自分に福袋を買おうと思ってなんかメンズ用の福袋買ってい
ます三角定規をいきなり50個買ってますね者から何を考えていたのでしょうか
その後100 l のドラム缶買ってるからねやっほぉ約おかしいを完全に犯す今ここ
でダークにしていいのがこの子ですね今年の1月10日に注文してますゲーミング
パッドか5ちゃ
ゲーミング pc に目覚めた月がありまして来ればゲーム絶叫少女
なんかかっこいいなってちょっと今年の性質を持ってていろいろちょっと買ってました
ねイヤホンの軍旗テーブルをめちゃくちゃいましたインスタントカメラを買った後の靴
を3つ買うと
2015年あんまり靴を買って中田の一回たくさん靴を買っていうことを持っ
に使ってますジャンボバルーン12ft 髭剃力
あってると思いきや2 da 書を買って右をカードを買い続ける東京に来たら悠遊
カード何でもあるんですけど静岡だと売ってない優良カードが多いんでどうしても
ネットで買っちゃうんですよねハードディスクの対応のチェスト
何を持ったのでしょうかこれでこの後大好きを買って術でスプレーを買ってマグネット
ボール216個買って心も完全にゲーム実況れざる気持ち
だけはもうピューディパイでしたお湯を張るを滑る買ったなぁの湯へ向かって
目覚まし時計はたくさん買って殴るゲーム実況したすぎていろんな機材を買ってたん
ですよ
こっそりほねほねザウルスかこれでここでいいよ80人に変えました今これは次は後で
いい朝活中に買いました70 d がもう壊れちゃってて秒速5センチメートルを見
たくなって買いました
風景
スクール2メートル超の最強ホッピングがユーチューバーマガジンもこっそり買って
ルアー見たの者先生がやー
よかったストアー他の警察官がとかこういう防弾シールド
個人的に買ってしまいましたなんかまた機会があれば使ってみようと思ってます
って空中浮遊する次世代ディスプレイスタンドここからベイブレードスイッチが入った
ときだね3ヶ月ぐらい前からベイブレードがスイッチが入ってますが運動会用の大玉を
買ったんですけどイマイチなんで買ったか分からなかった一般の玉を転がしするよと
いう中華鍋
を買ってからベイベーどの距離がましてはここで骨子を買いましたねこれはいい買い物
だったら神 t シャツ
ここから新居のカーテンとかを買ったりしています1000m の糸電話諸島て
1000m の糸を買ったり延期ショックのビリビリを全部買ったりして結局は優良
カードか
また位とかってんじゃんちょっと最近マイルールの拘束ドリルと釣りはを買ってるよ
何か動画
で使うと思ったんでしょちょっとここからまた今後の動画のでたにしようと思っている
のが多いのであまり言えないんですけど愛的で僕が今までアマゾンで買ってきたもの
でした
なんかこうに反して懐かしいと言うかなんか昔を思い出しますが
ユーチューバー関係ないものお客を買ったりしててやまず友情カードを愛して頂き本当
に amazon でしか物を買わないんであれが多分僕の全てだと思っていく
最も良いですまあ皆さんの何かの参考参考者ならないんですけどよかったら皆さんも
ぜひ amazon の購入履歴を振り返ってみてはいかがでしょうか
じゃあ
皆さん良い8月に入るので
4位
だぞじゃん
pa